hi Steve Harrison here with Jack
Canfield welcome back to our live cast
and anytime TV producer wants to put on
a great show they really try to line up
an all-star series of guests and there
are guests sometimes that are hard to
get and Tim Ferriss
is with us we're thrilled to have him
he's a hard to reach he's known as the
the author of the 4-hour workweek the
foyer body and because probably only
works four hours a week you know he
picks his media interviews closely and I
know that because he was mentored by you
Jack we're glad that he said yes to this
live interview I'm thrilled to have him
he's one of the coolest guys I've ever
met in my life
and I met him when he I think he was
like 26 years old and he was making like
65 thousand dollars a month and using
the Internet in a whole new way that in
the computer world and wanted to write a
book and I was fortunate enough to get
to know him and and learn Lots from him
but the thing was I was able to
introduce him to my agent who agented
the my success success principles book
and I get a really nice Christmas
present every year from that guy saying
thank you thank you thank you for
dissing me to tempest well Tim want to
welcome you to our show here thank you
for having me
yeah it's it's entirely my pleasure to
be here and pay it forward if I can in
any way well Tim you know I was saying
earlier that Jack is obi-wan Kenobi and
if he's obi-wan Kenobi you're Luke
Skywalker yeah well that's uh I'm a Star
Wars geek so I'll take I think obi-wan
Kenobi is much cooler than Luke
Skywalker why tends to be kind of whiny
but you know maybe that's maybe that's
also part of my makeup but I I will take
it and I am uh I've learned a lot from
Jack and we words I was just saying
before we came on Lama F because the
technology I think can be very confusing
to people I just said you know the box
of crayons has changed the toolkit may
have changed slightly but the principles
of the principles and I think you know
Jack really embodies how to apply them
repeatedly consistently and very few
people could do that we have we have
just thousands and thousand teen
eighty-four people watching our live
cast and one of the things that we know
is that a lot of them are thinking of
writing a book but they're they haven't
done it yet
okay there's they're often feeling
uncomfortable fearful doubtful maybe
afraid of criticism take us through your
journey I know that you began teaching
like a college course and then you had
this idea of the book it'll tell us a
little about how you decided to write
the 4-hour workweek the book was
somewhat accidental as Jack can attest
to so I really learned to hate writing
ah my senior thesis in school almost
killed me and I vowed I could do not add
to myself a four write anything longer
than an email ever again after after I
graduated and of course that hasn't
quite worked out the way I expected but
in the course of building my own
business after graduation started guest
lecturing at Princeton twice a year in
this high tech entrepreneurship class
which I really enjoyed I still go back I
tried to twice a year loves loved
teaching I've always loved teaching and
at one point I was traveling and trying
to sort through my existential crises at
the time and pull myself out of the
business all of the things that later
ended up in the 4-hour workweek and one
of the students who was very snarky
pretty typical Princeton stuff and I can
say that cuz I went there I said in the
comments the feedback forum said well I
don't know why you're teaching a class
of 50 students you should just write the
book and be done with it ha ha ha and so
these ideas kept occurring to me for
chapters or concepts or teaching or
headlines whatever and I couldn't get to
sleep I'm really bad insomnia so I
started writing down these notes just to
get back to sleep so I haven't a notepad
I'll write them down just go back to
sleep and they started to mount up mount
up mount up and I was in Argentina
dancing tango at the time long story
haven't read 4-hour work week and I had
a fair amount of time during the day so
I decided to put together a proposal
learn about publishing just for the hell
of it never ever not only did I not plan
on writing but I didn't want to write a
book and I
sir I got it all together I thought to
myself this is actually somewhat
interesting maybe not very interesting
and I sent it I sent the proposal to
Jack which at the time was called
lifestyle hustling terrible terrible
title terrible and I said it to Jack and
I said Jack am i completely crazy and
full of it or is there actually
something here and I'd really appreciate
your feedback and I developed a
relationship with Jack but mostly going
to Jack for sort of philosophical life
advice more than anything else so this
is the first time I had asked about the
publishing business and he wrote back I
remember and then he said actually I
really think there's something here you
should go forward to be perfect for Fox
and Friends and this and this and he
should meet these three people and and I
was a bit taken aback because as he
called my bluff I expected I was almost
hoping that he would say yeah this book
write anything I don't think it's for
you but you're great at this and this so
I go back to what you were doing and
instead he said no you should and I was
like oh boy here we go
and ended up meeting to Steve who's now
my agent and has been for ever since I
you know met him through Jack and that
just led me on this entire journey the
book was turned down by 26 out of twenty
seven publishers which sounds like a lot
until you hear what was it Jack for
Chicken Soup for the Soul
144 publishers yes then exactly so I
think the number of copies you sell is
proportionate to the number of people
who turned you down I think because you
I guess so basically jack is sold you do
you add million you had 62 six digits to
the end of the number of publishers and
then you've sold that or more copies of
your books but that was the journey it
was it was very uh it was made much
easier by having a couple of simple
introductions and tips from Jack and
then everything else flew that
everything else came from that not so
you mentioned that you find writing very
very difficult and I think that people
can really relate to that ones are
watching or or you know our live cast so
Tim you're now the author of the 4-hour
workweek the
for our body you've got this great book
give a little plug here the 4-hour chef
that will be coming out take a look but
give some what would you suggest to
people that are watching you and they're
saying you know what boy writing it does
seem pretty daunting what are some ways
of making it easier I'll tell you so the
the first four chapters I wrote for the
4-hour workweek I remember I had to toss
out because we're so pompous sounding
they were terrible like big Ivy League
words it was terrible terrible writing
it was boring to write and it was boring
to read so I tossed it and then I was
like all right I need to relax I need to
be funny so I tried funny and it was
like slapstick stupid it was so bad it
was like you know the a transcript of
the Three Stooges it was not it was not
good writing and then I decided you know
I'm just going to write this for the one
or two friends I have who are
experiencing the same problems I've kind
of figured out that's it and I'm going
to write to them as if I were sending an
email to them heartfelt email two
glasses of wine that's the tone like
I've had two glasses of wine I'm relaxed
I figured a couple of things I really
want to help one or two friends and
that's how I started to write it's funny
you say that because Jack was in
Philadelphia speaking to some of my
clients just last week and this was a
point that you really made that it's a
mistake that a lot people make is they
try to sound perfect or better they try
to sound bigger than they are and I
always say that you should talk and I
love what you said two glasses of wine
there was three cups of tea by Greg
Mortenson now up to cup and 1/2 glass of
IU - but the idea is that I talk like
right like I'm talking over the table to
someone we're having you know lunch how
would I talk to them so it's a very
transparent personal relaxed
conversation with someone I care about
hmm yeah go ahead Jim no I was just
going to add a couple of things so the
first even though I'm not a fiction
writer at this point who knows maybe
I'll try that and make a mess of things
but bird by bird first for all the
psychological trials and tribulations
bird by bird is the book that I read
when I feel like I'm going into the
abyss or having a complete meltdown it's
a wonderful book for getting out
that but I also would say like when
you're stuck when you're not sure what
to write tell a story so you like show
don't describe it show it so if you're
like oh how should I describe this point
do this do that like bullet point this
bullet point that give an example give a
story and just so what's an example of
how you did that in the 4-hour workweek
uh it well anytime I I hit a sticking
point which was very very very often I
would there were a couple things that I
would I would ask myself who whose story
can I tell like who embody is this point
or this principle I mean Jack obviously
is a master of this style of
storytelling and secondly PO Bronson who
is a great writer and has written many
many good books at one point I heard him
on a panel and somebody in the crowd
asked him about writer's block and and
you said well when I get writer's block
I think about what makes me really
really angry and I right about that and
it's actually fantastic advice if you
write about what most frustrates you why
it frustrates you and then like what you
did about it uh you usually come up with
something good and I would also
emphasize sorry I have a lot of thoughts
on this but that like the book is the
most important thing you need to bake
the product the market heading into a
good book like that's that for me that
is almost all of it and then the rest a
lot of it takes care of itself
but what I would say is make your quota
really small so two crappy pages a day
that's your quota for me that's the only
way I can slog through a book like not
happy pages a day this idea of to is is
I think we're hitting the number two
yeah all right yeah I cannot think of a
book or I'll just want to like cry into
my pillow and go to sleep I can't do it
well with job we have a question from
the live a chat here's love this name
somebody by name of eventual million
that's like s the site how did Tim
improve his writing skills if he never
thought he was a writer is it the
person's I'm not exactly a writer but I
got approached by two literary agents
what would you say I was yeah so for
improving writing I would say there are
a few there few keys so I I did
I did take the craft of communication
very seriously because you need to good
business but I never considered myself a
writer you don't need to be a good
writer in the literary sense you have to
have an authentic voice and that's it a
consistent authentic voice which is you
and I would say that to improve your
writing let's see on writing well is a
book that really helped me simple and
direct also another book that that
really helped me and what I would say is
you have to imitate before you can
create so if you really really love a
certain writer let's say Kurt Vonnegut
in my case is one writer I love imitate
his style try to write two pages as if
you were Kurt Vonnegut and then maybe
you maybe you turn out three pages of
garbage and then you get into your flow
and you know it's not garbage because
you needed those three pages to warm up
to get to the point that you eventually
use to start the factor and so let me
ask you this we have Michele Lopez from
Colorado hurt her question is in your
view is bad publicity worth it and we
have another question from I love this
name naughty photog for Tim havoc had a
handle sensitive material that freaks
people out of sexual nature is it
seriously this is both our biggest
selling point and a detriment I know a
for our body you came up with a really
killer teasing bullet that got you a lot
of publicity of a sexual nature yes yes
I did it
so I would say that just to address both
points I do believe there's such a thing
as bad publicity I do not agree that all
publicity is good publicity I think that
particularly in an age where Google real
estate is extremely important if you
have if you have earned somehow a bad
publicity I do not believe that it pays
positive dividends doesn't mean you to
cry over bad reviews either
but I don't go out of my way for bad
publicity certainly but on the flip side
related to the sexual content I don't go
out of my way avoid offending people
if it is a byproduct of me having a
strong opinion on something I think will
help a lot of my readers I am happy to
polarize I do not shy away from it so
I'm not going to you know needle someone
in a really offensive way just for
entertainment but uh if there is no
polarity if you don't take a strong
helpful stance on anything then you're
not going to create any debate you're
not going to create a discussion and in
a social world that lukewarm response is
going to kill you mmm yeah this you you
were able to get advice and from Jack
and feedback what do you think the
average person who is thinking about
writing a book can can really learn from
from Jack and just his many years of
experience as an author oh man I mean we
could we could go on a thought about it
but and I think that mr. Jack has it's
not like Jack had one successful book uh
Jack had to earn the success of that
first book more than almost anyone I
know and tried everything I may be the
sort of portfolio of things that were
thrown at the wall to see what would
stick is just my endemic to me and I
have tried a lot of stuff Jack has tried
everything under the Sun and then some
and I think that what's very important
when you're trying to create a
world-class book and have a world-class
launch let's say and world-class
longevity like hitting the bestseller
list from one week isn't interesting to
me hitting the bliss and staying there
for a couple years that's really
interesting to me and I think that you
know jack knows how to do all of that
and just as important being able to tell
you what to do and this is something
that's neglected I think is pointing out
what not to spend a lot time on and you
know I remember speaking to Jack really
early on at one point and there are many
tools to use again you have to pick your
weapon so to speak but we spoke way
early on and it was you know radio these
specific outlets really move books blogs
increasing in importance really have an
impact in
he's following ways and so I just
focused on those two things I mean that
was the launch of the first book hmm
yeah yeah and one thing I think you -
you know obi-wan Kenobi and Luke
Skywalker here one thing that you really
have in common is you're both I remember
I asked you on the teleseminar said well
Jack you know what do you say to people
just said well Jack got lucky with
Chicken Soup for the Soul and he's like
no no we were really strategic you know
and I know Tim you're extremely
strategic when it comes to your
marketing let's talk a little bit about
leverage you know getting influential
people this is something that Jack and
who we have a big emphasis on in
bestseller blueprint Tim this is
something that you identified for
yourself is to identify certain
influentials who could then do some of
the heavy lifting for you so that you
can save time talk a little bit about
how you did that with your books I did
it it's a long conversation but I'll
give the short the short version so the
80/20 principle versions of the advice
is if you are seeking out influential
people online so let's just say they're
bloggers chances are they they will be u
2 cube is very hard YouTube can work so
very hard to get the attention of a
youtuber with 2 million subscribers
they're getting hit a hundred times a
day and have a business manager in
Hollywood it's just it's just very hard
a lot of the top bloggers I can still be
reached if you think's number one is
you're not trying to sell a book
everyone in the world that's how you
fail in marketing you need to have a
sniper shot what that means is to hit
the New York Times list depending on
your week depending on your category
let's just say it's 10,000 books a week
ok Sunday to Sunday 10,000 books a week
be really specific in who you reach out
to and make sure that your content is
absolutely a perfect fit threading the
needle with their audience if don't
bother because if you were pitching the
New York Times and you had the wrong
section they're not going to run your
story same thing with a good blogger so
you have to have very very specific
targeting what I would say next is that
emailing those people is competing in
the most crowded channel possible so if
you have a little bit of lead time and I
would HIGHLY highly recommend it is that
you go
to appearances if you're going after
tech let's say know thy audience my case
my first my first target not my only
audience my first target because I
belong to that demographic it's 20 to 40
year old tech savvy males that's it
with a focus in San Francisco New York
and I start there so I know who I'm
going after then I would go to a place
like South by Southwest so X s sorry s x
SW comm Austin Texas every year that was
one of the tipping points for the 4-hour
workweek I would go there meet these
people in person hang out with them
don't pitch them get to know them it's
not a transaction and if you view it as
a transaction you will fail it has to be
a relationship that you cultivate over
time and you do that by getting them to
trust the messenger before the match
which it doesn't matter how good your
messages if they're worried about
putting you on the blog then having you
do something stupid and embarrass them
they're not going to do it I and I would
say lastly is don't don't pretend like
your product appeals to everyone so one
of the things that I did when I met
really good bloggers is I would ask them
a lot of a lot of questions and then
when they said well where do you up to
I'll say oh I'm working on my first book
book and I kind of leave it at that and
to be like well what's it about and I
let them lead the conversation in that
way and then I would just offer very
very gently I would say look I don't
think the whole book will be of interest
to you to be perfectly honest but
they're there one or two chapters maybe
20 pages total I'm happy to send you a
review copy my publishers give me a
bunch of them and I can just put a
sticky note on those two chapters I
don't expect you to promote it I don't
expect you to endorse it but I have a
bunch of these copies and you might
actually enjoy it so happy to send you
one if you'd like and that was the pitch
bloggers do not respond well to a hard
sell any more than you know call this
the New York Times would and I deal with
both of them and I'll tell you like you
know my blog my blog has more than half
the number of subscribers than the Wall
Street Journal so you should treat it
accordingly don't send me a crap don't
send me a crappy pitch I won't respond
and I know you you like to give bloggers
that have big followings exclusive
content and even
even as you're right because one of the
things that we've been emphasizing is
that you have to think marketing even
while you're writing the book you're
talking about got to build relationships
I know you structure some of your
content aren't you already thinking
about what blog this could go in as you
write as you write the book a little bit
or give some feedback on that yeah
absolutely yeah absolutely so the the
one of my writing tips would be to write
in a modular fashion so if you look at
the 4-hour body it's really a choose
your own adventure book and they're
about 50 books in one and you choose
prism interest you that makes it easy to
order which is a benefit to the reader
it makes it easy to write an order which
is also helpful when you hit a sticking
point one slam your head in a car door
okay so this is that I yeah let me ask
you this one thing what go ahead I don't
did you know I was just gonna say by
thinking about which blogs would be a
perfect fit for certain content it makes
your book better because you're not
being salesy you are answering the
question who is my reader and that is
the marketing who is my reader hmm great
point you know one of the things that
people watch this live cast they see
Jack Canfield with 47 New York Times
bestsellers they see Tim Ferriss Wow
you know the 4-hour workweek you know
and they and the 4-hour body and they've
seen this parade of best-selling authors
and they're hearing us talk about all
the success which really can be theirs
if they put together you know things in
the right way we've also talked Tim
about how there are benefits of just
being an author even if you don't become
a best-seller but the thing is people
hold themselves back there's fear doubt
you've mentioned that writing is
difficult I just saw a great quote from
you on Twitter the other day I can't
quote it exactly but it was something to
the effect that when we think about our
own insecurities and fears we forget
that everybody else has those as well
speak to their speaks tell us a little
bit about what advice would you give
that person who's thinking I really want
to be an author I really this sounds
exciting I want it I want to step
forward but I'm afraid of what I don't
know maybe people reject me or criticize
me or
would speak to that uh I would say that
Willie are a few things so and I have to
be very candid here so the first is uh I
got a blasphemer a very very successful
author at one point very successful and
he said to me if you're gonna write a
book write an effing book don't mess
around don't do me yeah okay because
it's more of a liability than anything
else I would say that you know writing a
good book or a book is like losing 100
pounds you can do system le and almost
get aren t the outcome if you follow a
certain recipe I think the jack is
better qualified than just about anyone
to offer that but I'm not going to say
that it's easy but I will say that the
process of attempting to write a book is
valuable even if it never gets published
okay
secondly if you write a book and publish
a book even if it is not a huge New York
Times bestseller who cares the most
important marketing article I've ever
read is called 1,000 true fans it's
written by Kevin Kelly who was the
founding editor of Wired if you could
handpick the thousand people in the
world who got your book delivered to
them in person and they read it from
cover to cover
would it be worth writing that book and
I would say absolutely and you can in
some ways engineer that that and how do
you do it because you know you a reader
and then you write the book then at
first and foremost you want to read and
then secondly that they want to read hmm
here's a question from Jenny Kinson she
said for Tim if Tim was starting right
now what a program like Jack's
bestseller blueprint would this help him
or would he do it the hard way
that's the question well I don't know
why I would do it the hard way so I
would I would go I would find the best
mentor someone who's actually done it
someone who's not speculator and you
know Jack has done it repeatedly many
many times over so I I don't know why if
you can afford it I don't know why
anyone would not do it but if you figure
out the value of your time I mean you
could spin your wheels for years on this
stuff and most people do and they
it'sjust I don't see I'll see the reason
to do it
III don't see the reason to make your
life harder than it has to be Jack we
were talking about there's a lot of
different things that you need to come
together to be successful as an author
and Tim is the poster boy for a lot of
different positive attributes in this
regard what do you see in his story that
that people can glean well I see two
things I think someone who you know one
of the great things that makes people
successful is being willing to be
teachable and to know that you don't
know and to be willing to go find out
and learn from the Masters one of the
chapters I have my book is a study with
the Masters and I'm not the only master
Tim it reached out to over the course of
his career but that willingness to say
okay I know that I don't know and I'm
going to find out and what Tim's done in
everything he's done is said who knows
the most about this I'm going to go
study with them whether it was people
for his book on you know how do you
exercise better what do you do
nutritionally how do you lose weight too
fast nose you know he spent a lot of
time and money traveling around the
world to study with the experts so when
you study with a master you can you can
speed things up you know in the book
outliers they talk about takes 10,000
hours to become a master and Tim has
proven over and over with you know he's
a Guinness Book World Record of the
number of tango turns it can be done in
a minute that you can speed it up if you
study with someone who's really good at
what they do and so hanging out with
people whether it's through a program or
through mentorship or through coaching
or through an audio program whatever
he's done that and pretty much every
area of his life and the second thing is
a relentless commitment to excellence I
mean a impeccability on a level that you
rarely see and you've heard three people
tonight say that Lisa Nichols Marilyn
subtle and now Tim that you've got to
write a good book and you have to care
passionately about what you do and then
do the best you can to make it the best
you can and to identify your audience I
see so many people try to be something
to everybody and you said you know Who
am I writing to let's Mitch it them and
we did it with chicken or niche books
did very well when we wrote to a
specific audience as opposed to the mass
public and
I think those are and then Tim is a he's
one of those people that really does go
and give before he gets I mean his
willingness to go out and really create
relationship with bloggers and to give
and to connect and to be real and to not
be like you know doing a transaction as
he said it's visibility credibility and
then profitability and he's a master at
that as well and and being in action
takers Tim speak to that a little bit
because you're known as gay the author
of the 4-hour workweek he must not work
a whole lot is kind of the thing and I
you know I know but but you're somebody
clearly who takes action how is that
talk to talk to us a little bit about
that well I would say just just to
address one point real well two points
really quickly because I think they're
important that I'll answer that the the
first is that the bloggers who ended up
helping me with let's say the 4-hour
workweek I'm still friends with those
people seven years later I found people
I connected with well I would be friends
with anyway who happened to be writing
about similar that thanks and we got
along and we still get along
uh secondly I would say as it relates ii
just just to encourage people is that i
still have days multiple days where i do
not write thing I am still paralyzed and
screwed up so I'm not getting everything
right I am succeeding despite that
because I follow a couple of rules
basically and that goes all in terms of
taking action I would say that people
are afraid to take actions they're
afraid of failure and which is never
really clearly defined but just
encourage people if you're considering
doing something writing a book quitting
a job whatever it might be is you have
to fear sit just like you goal set so
write down you know the worst things
that could possibly happen if you tried
X whatever it is you have a column of
those things second column is things I
could do to prevent these outcomes and
then third column is what can I do to
get back to where I am net out undo the
damage if any of these things happen you
run down and then you realize this is
this is a piece of cake this is nothing
this is completely recoverable if I even
if I completely flop and I think that's
what people need to do to take action
oftentimes okay so my
last question is what I call my my Tim
Ferriss question I've been looking
forward to asking you this Tim I don't
know if you've ever been asked this but
but how does the philosophy of Seneca
how does it how does it apply to writing
a book and promoting a book Wow Wow yeah
the this is the philosophy of Seneca
they're a couple of things
so Seneca as well as kata I won't go
into like a whole stoicism rant because
I love stoicism if you want if you want
an operating system for life I'll just
tell you my stomach my set and I can
thank you for the the softball pitch
after Jetta
the Seneca is would teach a few things
and he was the most successful
investment banker in Rome advisor to the
Emperor world famous playwright in that
day in Rome not just an idle philosopher
but he would say you need to learn so
for it for instance he would recommend
that you wear odd clothing which is
something actually I think was Cato did
to learn to only be embarrassed about
the things that are worth being
embarrassed about number one so don't
like pie in the face who cares like why
are you trying to impress people you
don't like anyway I get over it
second is that when you learn that the
most important things in life are not
dependent on let's say having a number
one New York Times bestseller but
they're dependent on the process and the
people you surround yourself with then
you you eliminate your fear of loss you
eliminate your fear of failure and then
you can do things that are seemingly
impossible and I would say that perhaps
perhaps those are two well the
principles that Seneca would it would
emphasize well I think that's a great
note to end on hey thank you so much for
the generosity of your time and giving
us your inspiring story and strategies
has been great to be with you yeah my
pleasure thanks for having me
well it keep it up that the fear of
family like a beer commercial I love you
man thank you for joining I'm here
really I'm here in in very large part
because of the early help and guidance
that you provided me so my
pleasure all right thanks take care see
you guys bye